well i want to read you this next story
um i think you're both wrong i think
dogecoin is incredible
i think i think dogecoin is no you're
incorrect
it's douchecoin you want to know why
you're wrong douchecoin dogecoin has
just made a bunch of people who don't
pay attention pay attention
and if in the end they trade dogecoin
for
bitcoin it's it's it's better isn't it
no i i don't know
i've been in this business for 10 years
and and
no one knows more about it than i do and
it's um
it's a gateway drug to getting wrecked
so people think that they are smart
enough to trade altcoins in a way that
they're going to get more bitcoin or
they're just going to be in it for a
minute and
but the fact is that once you step away
from
bitcoin you're entering the gambling
casino so it's the same
if ever you go to vegas and you go
across the
the room with all the slot machines and
you ask 100 people
how if they're winners in vegas 100
people say yeah i win all the time i'm a
big winner they're sitting there with a
smoke and a cigar
you know with thread bear with nothing
on their back and they're like i've been
winning in this for years and years
because the gambling mentality is such
you convince yourself that you're
you're going to win at this gambling
thing so that's number one i do
and number two the projects themselves
suck uh they're all centralized garbage
bitcoin is decentralized it's a big
difference um
and you can't compare the two it is it's
i'm not saying dogecoin
technologically or their infrastructure
their code i'm saying a bunch of
regular people young people who had no
interest at all in any capacity
with cryptocurrency all of a sudden now
the door was opened to
at least walking into the room and if at
the end of it
10 of the people or one percent of those
people who normally would never be
involved are like
i'm gonna buy bitcoin with it because
that that's that's that's the real asset
so they bought some dogecoin as a joke
it went up they went whoa they sold it
then they you know got bitcoin instead
isn't it well it's like
is the house and everybody else are the
are the trumps on the floor
so i own bitcoin if somebody wants to go
into the speculative world of gambling
on douchecoins
uh and ultimately all that capital the
size of the market is expanding right so
it's a 2 trillion plus
and that means that ultimately more
money will flow into
bitcoin bitcoin goes through cycles and
right now it's going sideways and it's
building a base and then it'll make a
big leap
again and then you'll see rotation out
of all these altcoins
into bitcoin uh and a lot of people will
get wrecked
i mean also when you're trading in those
all kinds there's all kinds of tax
liabilities you have to be aware of
absolutely uh there's just it's just
it's not worth it instead of just that's
my shirt
huddle huddle baby huddle that's what
it's all about don't make me get
undressed tim
don't make me get naked on your show
please don't get on your tongue
i'm not saying dogecoin is better
bitcoin i'm saying dogecoin has a
marketing campaign
got a bunch of people to finally know
what crypto was they're going to get
wrecked so
people who bought it last week on the um
you know elon musk on saturday night
live at 72 or 74 cents a
coin they're setting out 30 or 40 losses
today and they're wondering what the
heck am i going to do it's going to
scare a lot of people out they're going
to
they're to not you you answer into the
arithmetic of losing the amount of
percent gain you need to break even once
you lose 10
is more than 10 right so uh you know you
and then
you what happens is you tend to to trade
riskier projects as is today there's
another coin
that's a dog right so now that had a
rally today so a lot of people who lost
30 percent on doge in the last week are
going to be i'm going to make it back
on this other thing which is even more
ridiculously cool so they end up with
zero
so let's let's let me ask you about
bitcoin though if for one there's a
finite amount of bitcoin
it's gonna it's it's not they're not
gonna complete the 21 million
uh coins until when do you know what you
know 100 years another hundred years
yeah so
if if look we we i was talking with some
uh some of the people here at tim cast
earlier
and one of the suggestions was like why
don't you buy like do a video where you
buy something big with bitcoin and i was
like
because i'd rather have the bitcoin why
would i why would i give it up for
anything
you know the tesla says you can buy a
you know a tesla with a bitcoin i'm like
i'd rather have the bitcoin
it's like why would why would i spend a
million dollars on a 50 000 car
yeah bitcoin's gonna hit a million bucks
yeah and i think it's gonna be a lot
faster than most people realize
so i guess the challenge is right now
should people uh
you know uh should hypothetical people
who are working
just be buying as much bitcoin as
possible but keeping some of the fiat
for regular use
rent food because you don't want to
spend the bitcoin you want it for later
yeah right
at what point are you like okay now i
can spend bitcoin when it
it becomes um a greater parity to gold
so gold's worth about 10 trillion
dollars let's call it bitcoins worth of
1 trillion or so
when you see bitcoin trading at parity
to gold at around 500 000 a coin or 10
trillion dollars worth
then i think it'll be it'll be
transition from
the pure only store of value to store
value and medium of exchange it's not
really a medium of exchange as such
although on what's called the second
layer with
uh lightning and other applications
built on top people are using it as
uh for transactions every single day and
a lot of people who do transact in
bitcoin that might spend bitcoin
uh let's say a thousand dollars of the
bitcoin they'll immediately buy a
thousand to to replenish that a lot of
people the most intelligent thing you
can do is dollar cost averaging
which is just every single day or every
week or every month you simply put in
10 bucks 100 bucks or a thousand bucks
into uh bitcoin on a regular basis
you know we we work with i think you
know swan bitcoin is a company that is
specializes in this
and we we we work with them pretty
closely i got i got an email from
someone
somebody who has like a was a wealthy
individual who had a trust like a
wealthy family
yeah and they were talking to their
financial manager whatever saying we
need to start
putting our assets into bitcoin and they
said absolutely not we won't do that
yeah and so the email i got was like
very upset like what are we supposed to
do
well that's that's understandable the
the entrenched you know the
establishment in these markets don't
want to the competition
and they don't want people taking money
out because once a lot of people
understand that
you know the saying goes not your keys
not your bitcoin you take the keys off
these exchanges and these products and
you and so you're taking money out of
the system
so for if you're uh somebody who's
business is accumulating assets under
management aum
and that's a negative for you because
people are taking all their assets off
and they're
they're putting into cold storage and so
that's that's
they don't want that competitive thing
going on and that the the amount of
money
made on selling products is enormous
and this is uh up there's no fees
attached
it's it's it's free to store essentially
uh
so they don't want the competition and
but
uh that is changing quite rapidly as
paul tudor jones very famous hedge fund
manager said
he believes inflation is here and he he
owns a lot of gold
but he says bitcoin is the fastest horse
in the race
um how long until you think bitcoin
reaches
half a million well i i haven't got a
price target for 20 21
of 220 000 per coin why what what was it
based on the havings that we've had
every four years we've had three
halvings
and uh typically you see these types of
price moves and the the year you can
track a pattern
yeah that's that's cyclically what we
say what's the habit well so once again
uh
has the price tracked as you've
predicted it thus far because i know you
might
yeah the first quarter it did it did
very very well now it's kind of going
sideways
and i think we're going to see in the
second quarter another breakout move
to to um you know in 70 80 85 000.
so i i've known you guys for a decade
and uh
i i told you the story of bitcoin back
in 2011 i was at a hackerspace in l.a it
was called crash base i was hanging with
my friend jeff
and i were sitting on my computer i had
savings i had about five grand in
savings i had worked i had saved it i
never going to touch it it's my rainy
day fund it's like i'm very proud i was
you know was like 24 or something
and i said i saw bitcoin so the bitcoin
faucet for those aren't familiar there's
a website that literally just gave you
free bitcoin it was .05 i believe
could be wrong just randomly like there
you go here's some because it was almost
worthless
so i looked into my friend and i'm like
should i just buy a bunch of this
bitcoin thing
because i'm just saving this money it's
sitting in a bank
you know i got to pay fees or whatever
why don't i just buy this bitcoin and he
goes
ah nah dude like it's probably a scam
you're gonna buy it off some dude and
then it's gonna become worthless and i
was like
yeah uh i guess not and so i was
actually no joke sitting there about to
buy like 7 300
you know bitcoin yeah at 70 cents and
then i remember when it went up to five
bucks
and i was like oh man remember when i m
my when jeff when you told me i had to
buy
then hit 20 bucks same story then it hit
500.
and what's funny is so i remember when
you guys were promoting bitcoin like
crazy
and i was just watching it like yeah but
now it's at you know five bucks
if only i had bought was a dollar now
it's at sixty thousand dollars and i'm
like
why didn't i listen to max well that
story is the exact same story that peter
schiff has experienced
yeah but he's taught him about a dollar
i told him about ten dollars i told him
about a hundred dollars i told him a
thousand dollars told him about ten
thousand dollars and he still
won't buy it he's still anti-bitcoin
he's still saying the same
silly things over and over again i have
been common story i was buying though so
so
you know what i like i'm like man i
should have bought i'll buy some i'll
buy a little bit
but i never went gung-ho i never went
full in i just bought a little bit here
and they're like yeah well i'll just
have some
well it's never too late you know this
it's it's gonna continue to go up you
know
on this financial advice question it's
like
we're setting the table we're saying
look here's inflation here's your
options
here's what people are saying you know
and make your own choices
do your own research but it's a very
compelling story
and and and given that what the track
record has been
and that nothing we've said that would
happen hasn't happened
pretty much we've been absolutely spot
on in predicting
the last 10 years pretty much every
major turn in the global economy
i'm definitely going to be buying uh
more bitcoin but what bitcoin what do
you think about ethereum though
it's centralized garbage you don't like
aetherium [ __ ]
nah that's fine well so i'm not going to
pretend that ethereum is the same thing
as bitcoin i think
no it's centralized it's it's got it's
the transactions are reversible they've
reversed transactions before
sixty percent pre-mined it's the it's an
exit scam where metallic and those guys
are just dumping coins whenever they
feel like it
wow um it's uh it's not robust at all
it's uh
buggy it's never been no one knows how
many exist
if you say what you can't run a node
what is it ethereum
exactly what is it like what's the point
of it
so there's there's applications run off
of it using erc20 tokens
so why not use microsoft why not use ada
yeah
all of the all of the nobody run nobody
can run a node it costs too much
it's all hosted on aw aws that's true
so you can shut it down do you think uh
do you think aws is gonna listen
you know to vitalik buterin or are they
going to listen to the treasury if the
treasury contacts them no
i i agree so i i think i view ethereum
as is very very different from bitcoin
it's more of like an investment into a
company
yeah bitcoin and if they're a lot better
companies than to invest in this
but if you're i don't know but if your
objective is to
what everything that that bitcoin offers
as we've discussed about it that's your
objective there's there's bitcoin
if you want to get involved in something
called ethereum which is some software
that is
buggy and it's centralized and it has a
track record of malfeasance
that's an option people i want to be
medici i want to be my own bank i want
to be the central bank i want to have
my own country within me and i don't you
know ethereum doesn't give that no other
coin gives that just bitcoin
are you saying you've invested in
nothing other than bitcoin that's all we
did yeah nothing else
you guys should create points no you
can't it's like
like as soon as there's an individual
who can be identified
and that person can then take the coin
down
the treasury contract yeah i think that
that's centralized i think the future of
currency is like
you make max coin stacey coin ian coin
you guys are not investing in anything
outside of bitcoin like so we have we
have bitcoin
we have invested in uh bitcoin startups
like for example
kraken which is an exchange when it was
five million dollars we invested in it
it's now
uh worth uh 10 billion dollars
swampbitcoin.com four slash orange
pillow we
we find we spawn yeah we finance them
yeah no like regular stocks of like you
know blue chips or
hundreds or anything um no because
um we there's a couple of interesting
companies that are bitcoin related
so microstrategy has a big bitcoin
position
square which is jack dorsey's company is
really a big on the bitcoin vanguard
so i have positions i have small
positions in these in these uh
in these companies that have bitcoin
related uh investments
in uh what year was it was 2012 i was
hanging out with you guys and i was i
was
filming for some show and yes you guys
you were filming some guy
some rich guy and he was like you got to
buy square and squares like 13 bucks
yeah and so i was you know i was mostly
broke and i was like all right i'll buy
some
and i did not regret it oh good so i i
tell these stories about how i wish i
bought bitcoin but the reality is
just standing next to you guys hearing
you guys talk about square
right and then well actually and squares
up a lot oh yeah especially from back
then square is huge
so uh for those that are familiar with
when i went on the on the joe rogan
podcast with jack dorsey
i said before we start the show like i
should do a disclaimer that i own some
shares in square not that much
like very very little because i was
broke when i bought into it yeah yeah
but now it's like
yeah well we have some gold and silver
from our gold and silver days but we use
it as collateral to buy bitcoin
wow so what do you mean collateral like
taking out loans bitcoin
that's a good that's the way uh wealthy
people do it right you don't want to
pay taxes because as soon as you sell
anything you have to you have to do your
capital yeah we started buying gold at
the 400 range if you borrow
again so so you go to a bank what do you
do you you say like hey i want 100 grand
to buy bitcoin and you buy bitcoin in a
month
you go to a bank yeah you put up your
gold and silver's collateral
you take out a loan so then a month
later because bitcoin is just
skyrocketing you just pay back the loan
and then you got free bitcoin
you pay it back out of your earnings
like whatever so you don't have to
uh pay the capital gains right on block
fi you can put crypto up
as collateral yeah it's a huge market
but um
but you do have to give up your keys
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i give it that so
it's not worth it can't go to block five
if dollars are going down
and we're like man is this bad and
bitcoin is going up this is great
yeah and you can go to a bank and
they'll say we will give you the dollars
to buy bitcoin yeah
that seems like a no-brainer yeah all
right so not telling anybody
gold and silver are going up and so is
the bitcoin
right so my collateral is going up as
well as what about property though
property's good
property is a sitting duck because you
have property taxes which are going to
go up and you can't
it's also not very you know i think it's
going to be
it's not liquid bad times when you have
what i think is going to be a very
troubling
uh time and you need to move and
leave let's say the country for example
you can't really take your
property but you can't take your bitcoin
you just memorize a seed phrase and you
can go through the airport naked
and you can have any amount of bitcoin
but it's with you
but it's uh i mean you want to have you
don't want to just only have bitcoin
right you don't have other things
i'd imagine like you want to maybe focus
heavily on bitcoin but i'd imagine well
what happened over the last 10 years is
that the since the price went from a
dollar to 55 000
it has now become
dwarfed everything else in the portfolio
we invest
invest in yourself that's the best thing
absolutely that's
like better than any stocks or whatever
because you know as
as you see like somebody somebody like
biden can come along and say
okay capital gains is not 20 it's going
to be 43
and you're like dude i heard like
exactly i i heard a great quote earlier
today though they said um
when when it all hits the fan and a
bitcoin is worth a million bucks
yeah do you know how many bullets it
would cost to get to get a million
dollars in bitcoin
one right not necessarily not with a
multi-sig wallet
if you have a multi-sig wallet in cold
storage then no
no i'm not a bullets can get your
bitcoin yeah yeah but you get the point
you know well the the famous five dollar
wrench attack
the five dollar wrench attack yeah yeah
yeah so but that's
that's that but it i would say in an
extremist
bitcoin is probably the most secure
because um
gold and silver can easily be
confiscated by the government or stolen
and it's
tough to ensure and keep in a vault and
you have your house can be
taken away as the houses have been taken
away yeah money can be cancelled
once you put money in the bank you know
technically it's owned by the bank
you don't own it more right so that's
the capital i guess that can read your
mind
right so with bitcoin it's actually in a
total breakdown it's the only form of
wealth which is actually secure
how about so how about all the money
that uh police deal across america
what if electricity goes down well
actually now bitcoin is being beamed via
satellite from block stream so you don't
need the electrical grid to be working
you can you can set up uh a bitcoin
password that's just like a regular old
password you remember right
you can do yeah so you can create a
phrase that's really easy for you to
remember but really hard for a computer
to correct like a 12 to 24 word phrase
yeah yeah so i always tell people like
good passwords it's like a song lyric or
something or
just a sentence usually you get a random
word generator which you can find online
and they just generate random words but
that's not better than
it can be because the uh i believe in in
this case
the best place to go for information
about that is called bitcoin.page and
that is run by jamison lopp and he's
like one of the top security experts in
the space so
you know i i wouldn't take your uh
security advice from uh
you know from us right now i would go to
the top guy jameson lop bitcoin.page and
it has all the security stuff how to
how to create the best pass phrases and
all that yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you